they can still have multiple partners
well they can but i'm sorry
you're allowed to call her at home but
she's allowed to beat her yeah
what's her provocative because it's her
right her body oh it's it's it's her
body but it's not oh god but i'm just
saying the name put on it like you said
that's a hoe that's that's the label
you're choosing to everyone but but
again we can't we can't get rid of our
biological differences and men men
biologically had to ensure paternity so
there's a reason they're disgusted by
multiple partners with a woman because
historically if there was a girl that
was sleeping around he could not ensure
paternity and you can't make that even
though it's not even though it's not
like
even though even though even though it's
not it's not like we don't like it and
it might it's probably not convenient
today because most of the girls you like
are probably attractive and they
probably have had multiple partners but
like
but but what i'm saying is like even
though it's not like fun they can't they
cannot and women
yeah they can't get rid of their biology
where women we what we're attracted to
is like status you know height success
money
reliability